nuit la russie a engagé une attaque
militaire massive contre l'ukraine en
refusant la voie diplomatique en
choisissant la guerre le président
poutine n'a pas seulement attaquée
l'ukraine il a décidé de bafouer la
souveraineté
de l'ukraine il a décidé de porter la
teinte la plus grave à la paix à la
stabilité dans notre europe depuis des
décennies les sanctions porté à la
russie seront à la hauteur de
l'agression dont elle se rend coupable
mes chers compatriotes
les événements de cette nuit sont un
tournant dans l'histoire de l'europe et
de notre pays
ils auront des conséquences durables
profonde sur nos vies ils auront des
conséquences sur la géopolitique de
notre continent et nous serons ensemble
y répondre